the Joe Rogan experience when you first
started fighting how much striking
training had you done before you decided
to compete in MMA because you had this
rest base did you have any striking
training growing up did you do any I'd
lock system boxing yeah and I did some
some karate too I didn't know any pseudo
okay I did Tang Soo if like few years
from the time I was like 13 to like 16
that makes sense cuz you always had good
kicks yeah yeah like that Shawn salmon
knockout but you know I never I never
utilized my kicks like I said over my
mom will always be like every time and
Rashad listen Joe Joe she's always the
same something Joe Cocker said wish I
Joe Rogan said you need to pass the
guard she she's the one who told you
that Rashad throw your kicks like Bruce
Lee Rashad and then and the next day I
talked on the phone she said Rashad that
was a good kick and I was like okay sure
but I don't like that dirty [ __ ] though
and I was like mom would you talking
about Rashad you knew he was knocked out
you didn't have to hit him again oh I
can't you can't tell you've got to keep
going like the referee say don't stop
until I stop you and I was just in the
fight and she said but still Rashad [ __ ]
so funny yeah I was kind of surprised
that you were in head kicking more
people unconscious after that you know I
that's the thing man I needed I needed
to really really step out of my game and
make sure I stepped out of my game more
and more often but I just you know after
I switched switch things up and went
went from you know Jacksons to uh to
Florida it was different because Mike
Winkeljohn he was my guy like it was
like me and Mike Winkeljohn
had a really good relationship and he
would he would work with me and we and a
lot of times we would work together it
was like it was like a counseling
session we would just talk about life
you know I'm saying in between in
between stuff we talk about everything
and it was a fun training session you
know and and that's when you know he'll
instill in me all these different things
you know he'll be like oh yeah that that
kick is gonna work that kick is gonna
work you know even with the overhand
right when I'm called chocolate dough he
was telling me oh yeah that's the kick
that's the best punch is gonna catch
them that's gonna catch him that we're
not when I caught Chuck the day before I
was hitting it move super nervous and I
was hitting the overhand right and a
left hook combination and then you say
oh yeah that's that's that's gonna be
the punch you know you and him with that
and you cannot come out and I'm not
gonna be able to get into the cage and
graduate you that's what he said to me
word for word and I was like no way and
then it happened I looked at almost like
oh it happened just like you said that
was like a gunshot
I remember that shot I remember you land
that shot this smack of your fist
hitting Chuck and then seeing Chuck
crumbles like holy [ __ ] was that you a
most satisfying victory yeah I think so
I it definitely was just because like
going into that fight job like the media
sometimes can be so damn disrespectful
you know what I'm saying like they were
just kind of like the questioning was
like you know what have you even done to
fight a guy like chocolate dough like it
people are asking me yeah I mean pretty
much in so many words like you know what
do I even but he would already at that
point in time had you fought for the
title no that was before your title yeah
before a fought for the title and you it
was the fight before the fight before
right a fight before yeah only God she
has to fight for the title because I
beat chuckling chuckling that was
supposed to fight for the title that was
to serve up to fight for the title oh
yeah wow yeah that was that was the
service well the media was a little
sloppy back then yeah so so there's some
really good guys out there now and gals
that are covering MMA with a real
journalist they really a real sports
journalist
like anybody with a camera who like
fights was also a lot of people that
were trying to get attention just by
being douchey yeah there's a lot of
douchey sports guy talk yeah I can hate
that stuff that that was driving me
crazy
you'd be real disrespectful to fighters
real dismissive of fighters so going
into the fight
I felt that disrespect I was like you
know what ma'am all right I'm like I
don't care what happens I'm like this
like I got I got a leash at least give a
good showing for myself you know mmm and
that's and that's all I really cared
about doing you know I went out I walked
out to the song the board of technique
is called that's my boy yeah I love that
he's my friend
oh yeah that's cool man love him yeah I
came out to the song point of no return
and that song just really solidified
everything I was feeling at that moment
you know like I kid you know there's a
verse in here it says you know the place
that I'm from doesn't exist anymore
and I knew after I walked out to that
fight
you know life would never be the same
whether I wanted lost so that was the
big moment that was the big moment there
was no that I was not going to be the
same Rashad after that fight no matter
what happened immoral technique as such
great lyrics he's so smart so smart
I'm so politically aware geopolitically
aware he's got so much depth to his
lyrics I love that dude yeah he's like
one of those guys you listen to and you
just kind of keep putting it back he's
got a lot of [ __ ] oh [ __ ] a lot of
things that he says you know you going
you look it up out the words like okay
you know he definitely had me looking up
some things that I listen to
[Applause]